bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados
yakarta la capital de indonesia se está
hundiendo y sus habitantes padecen año
tras año brutales inundaciones este y
otros problemas llevaron al presidente
yo como ídolo a impulsar un plan para
mover en la capital a otra de las islas
del país y el parlamento ya aprobó una
ley para lograr esta titánica empresa
porque se está hundiendo la capital
indonesia es factible cambiar de sitio a
toda una ciudad y cuáles son los
desafíos de este megaproyecto yakarta
enfrenta serios problemas es una de las
ciudades más contaminadas del mundo la
polución en su aire causa problemas de
salud a 5,5 millones de personas al año
está sobrepoblada fue planeada
inicialmente para 500 mil habitantes y
hoy alberga a más de 10 millones de
personas está también el desafío del
cambio climático los tres ríos que la
atraviesan se desbordan con frecuentes
lluvias monzónicas mientras que el nivel
del mar que crece un centímetro por año
amenaza ferozmente a sus costas pero el
más grave de sus problemas es el
hundimiento de sus suelos algunas áreas
de la ciudad principalmente en el norte
frente al mar dejaba se hunde en hasta
25 centímetros por año esto se debe a la
falta de una red de agua potable en la
ciudad para 2015 solamente el 40 por
ciento de la población contaba con
alcantarillado y acceso a agua potable
así los ciudadanos tienen que obtener el
líquido cavando pozos para extraerlo de
acuíferos subterráneos el problema con
el bombeo de agua es que la capa de roca
porosa que hay debajo al no rellenar pse
de agua se contrae causando el
hundimiento también del suelo y es un
problema que se agudiza con el tiempo en
situaciones normales el agua de lluvia
volvería a llenar los acuíferos
manteniendo la firmeza pero al estar la
ciudad pavimentada el agua nunca se
repone cerca del 40 por ciento de su
territorio está ya por debajo del nivel
del mar y la ciudad podría estar bajo el
agua para 2050 en 2012 el gobierno
construyó un muro para intentar contener
el océano pero este presenta fugas y no
logra a proteger a la ciudad de sus
peores inundaciones en la actualidad hay
un proyecto de crear una barrera
artificial en la bahía de yakarta pero
su financiación es todavía incierta en
medio de esta situación al presidente
huido lo encarnó la propuesta de hacer
una nueva capital en qué consiste el
proyecto aquí es donde se construirá la
nueva ciudad en un terreno a dos mil
kilómetros de yakarta en una zona de la
selva de kalimantán en la isla de borneo
la nueva urbe se llamará nusantara un
vocablo local para referirse a todas las
islas del archipiélago indonesio el
proyecto busca construir unas 180
hectáreas y está valorado en 34 mil
millones de dólares el estado financiera
el 19% de la construcción de la ciudad
mientras que el resto del proyecto
estaría financiado por inversores
privados las obras iniciaron este 2022
ya se empezaron a despejar terrenos ya
construir vías se espera que la primera
fase de la construcción esté lista para
2024 y que para entonces puedan recibir
allí 17 millones de ciudadanos
principalmente función del estado qué
desafíos plantea el megaproyecto sus
defensores aseguran que ayudará al
crecimiento económico en una región
subdesarrollada y que la urbe
distribuirá mejorar la riqueza del país
entre sus doscientos sesenta y siete
millones de habitantes aseguran que será
ambientalmente sostenible pensada para
que obtenga toda su energía de fuentes
renovables también para dedicar el 10%
de sus terrenos para producir alimentos
y que el 80 por ciento de la movilidad
se haga en transporte público en
bicicleta oa pie pero también genera
muchos interrogantes la financiación
está todavía en vilo muchos de los
inversores que han demostrado interés no
se han comprometido realmente con el
proyecto y hay incertidumbre frente a su
desarrollo futuro y es que el mandato de
wedo terminará en 2024 por lo que
dependerá de los políticos de las
próximas generaciones llevarlo a cabo y
administrarlo tras los grandes desafíos
que provocó la pandemia
el proyecto también ha sido criticado
por haberse aprobado muy rápidamente y
sin haber es realizado suficientes
consultas públicas
sin contar con los expertos ambientales
que advierten que la edificación de no
sentará amenaza a una de las selvas
tropicales más antiguas del mundo y a
todos los seres vivos que la habitan
por otro lado pasarán décadas antes de
que la nueva megalópolis pueda ser
completamente habitable y no se sabe qué
pasará con los 10 millones de habitantes
que viven en yakarta cuando el gobierno
abandone la ciudad para muchos analistas
gran parte de la ciudadanía permanecerá
en yakarta y a menos de que se
solucionen sus problemas de acueducto
seguirán enfrentándose al hundimiento de
la ciudad entre tanto el tiempo sigue
ocurriendo y el nivel del mar ha
aumentando si le sirvió el vídeo para
entender el curioso traslado de la
capital indonesia y sus desafíos los
esperamos en otro episodio de cinco
minutos en france 24 y france24 puntocom